[Music]
with dignity and respect
committed to free speech training
straight talking and direct we may act
eight each other and you thought
provoking provocative and controversial
[Music]
hello and welcome to the pledge it's
been a trying week for the prime
minister who managed to lose her Johnson
during a crunch vote on Heathrow
expansion he eventually turned up in
Afghanistan well I'm pleased to say our
Johnson is on proud display for all to
see
after making good on her pledge to
appear on the pledge and coming up
rachel says you're not being served Phil
wants jobs for our veterans June thinks
cheap buys are going out of fashion and
Michelle says swearing celebrities can f
off but first it's me okay agreed at
first sight it does look a little
draconian but as nothing else seems to
be working
would it be so wrong to consider taking
council housing away from the families
of anyone found guilty of belonging to a
gang the idea was put forward by Home
Office Minister Victoria Atkins who
backed a scheme being trialed in North
London
she said threatening whole families with
eviction will teach these vile thugs to
quotes understand the consequences of
their criminal behavior damn right they
murder deal drugs and terrorized
neighborhoods while laughing at the
authorities surely being told they could
see mum made homeless would have some
impact with these low-lives
[Music]
can I put you down as a yes
I speechless speechless for starters
there is no evidence whatsoever that
these sorts of measures work I'm
challenged in a minute challenge me
please do but also in the case of young
people who turn to crime a lot of the
time most of the time their parents are
completely distraught the parents have
tried everything to get that child back
on track look majority of young people
if you look at the 73,000 young people
we have in gangs the majority of them
their parents not saying this is a good
idea so what makes you think that the
idea of their families becoming homeless
is a deterrent well often they are
selfish young people who are only
thinking about themselves so I'm sorry
the idea of this is insane and then if
we're looking at families what does that
mean for the children of these criminals
so then the pressure on the state of
these children end up in our welfare
system it's absolute insanity and what
she should be doing is looking at how we
get to the causes of these young people
turning to crime and here's my challenge
was you're not a police officer I'm not
a police officer
we're journalists and broadcasters why
don't we hear from someone who wasn't
just a police officer Metropolitan
Police Superintendent former Met Police
Superintendent Leroy Logan who oversaw a
similar scheme in Hackney some years ago
it was a sufficient deterrent because
when you start influencing the roof over
someone's head all on a sudden everyone
focuses
had a massive impact on reducing
antisocial behavior improving parental
control and not just within the vicinity
where they lived but it also helped the
child engaging in schooling and being
more productive all round so just to
play some of those works back to you
June and then I'll bring someone else in
sufficient - Tarun influencing the roof
over someone's head massive impact
improving parental control engaging in
school tell me that's a form of copper I
wouldn't see the actual statistic so
he's lying I don't believe it you don't
believe it so that's the best can we
hear from somebody he's also dealt with
the impact of the
policy and this is a a youth worker
Jennifer Blake if you've got a young
person that's in gangs and they decide
to move her family and the family's got
another four children and they're all
under the age of ten then Social
Services has a duty to house them so
therefore they're gonna house them in
another borough so you're just pushing
the problem to another borough yeah I
mean I can understand why it sounds good
because it's very much fits into the
Tory Party of war and louder tough on
crime tough on the causes of crime that
was the Labour Party by the way that
said tough on crime tough on the causes
remember do go on tough on crime they're
not and that is the biggest problem in
all of this if the punishments really
were and you say draconian I'm medieval
with my punishment so I'm telling you no
really screwing people in properly I'm
telling you I would be winding behavior
what you mean in the coffin is
interrogating properly no joke you know
but what I am saying is they're just
getting away with stuff at the moment
right the problem why ever what you're
saying is all right
you've got other people within these
estates looking around to going I'll
tell you what who grassed that family
and then you're gonna report many
estates of people going about this
family knew the whole family yeah what
do you want to move back into the house
would you want to live in the house
afterwards we're all staying in other
gang members gonna tell you what we'll
take a little bit of Penance on em
people okay another social problem with
people going live because nothing else
is working
listen performing you in Michelle let's
just let's just give you an idea or the
viewers an idea this is let's go to
Richmond and see some footage here of
the sort of people we talk about now you
have two people who apparently had been
loitering these at a classic gang we
don't know that these members going but
this is the sort of behavior wearing
motor they go over to a young woman
whither to Richmond full of viewers who
don't know is one of the more affluent
parts of London she very bravely tucks
the child away doesn't give a purse or a
watch or whatever it is those two make
off now this is the most fascinating
part the scaffolding lorry pulls up
they've seen what's going on and out
they come I say again
daylight people walking past young mom
it just happens to be in an affluent
part of Britain that shouldn't be make
any blind bit of difference but that's
that is what we're contending with
Michel see I've seen that video I think
that is absolutely disgraceful and what
I also think is disgraced dis first of
all is you'd have noticed that that
scaffold I grabbed a bit of metal before
he chased after those guys
how do you've caught those robbers and
given them you know smack without metal
the scaffold air would wither the one
that was in trouble so I have a real
issue with that but I agree
wholeheartedly with you we are in a
situation where that kind of stuff is
going on in our streets and okay
predominantly in London at the moment
but it won't be long before it spreads
we're beyond that and nothing is working
and the reason that nothing is working
is there's no consequence so these
people think that they can jump on
mopeds drive up to the likes of you and
I or anyone else steal whatever they
want
they don't give a damn about what we've
seen in crime with gangs saying is
actually I will give and I will give
these guys some credit in the sense of I
think that they probably care for their
mom I would say not really I was it
would not say not really I think I would
say they've stopped listening to their
parents of words they would not be
involving themselves in that sort but I
think June's right I think what we're
seeing is gangs have replaced family as
community and there's no absolutely no
point in punishing families for gangling
but it can be blocking up a long time
when you say I'll give you a free month
suspended sentence that's all right
innit no it's not right no you're taking
the taking things in doing that you
absolutely bring in things that low that
you know these people can understate
smelly over-the-top and by the way you
know I mean they really are low can we
look at the type of stuff that does
actually work which is about education
and which is yes it is actually because
all the statistics show you education is
the best way to turn and what
very unfashionable I think those two
lads who went after that girl have any
interest in going to school and learning
the rhythmic training there's not lock
them up and throw away the key
can I show a clip please from Professor
Simon Harding who actually is talking
some sense let's have a look at him in
terms of preventing people from moving
in we have to address the issue of
poverty that means large scale in
structural investment into these areas
that we have largely abandoned and
building communities as Rachel said the
gangs have replaced the family and it
takes a village to raise it the parents
are stretched they cannot cope an age
and schooling is what the Met Police
achieved in Hackney they kids went to
school I want to see more data on that
June they're also proposing this it's
alongside some of the things that you're
sayings and they're not saying we're
just gonna go in and on the first
instance take a house and that's it so
this is a measure as a last chance
saloon and by the way these people they
choose to be in gangs and often they
choose to be in gangs because gangs are
seen as glamorous I honestly think that
those people like on the mopeds are
doing all this stuff there must laugh at
the likes of you and I going to work and
earning some money when they could just
rob from you I would say if we had
actually train them properly and allowed
them to contribute to society you've got
to look at what happens to a lot of
these children you're a vicious little
hood who tries to run from bound from
school yeah but don't you first but you
were written off
yes about those written off children
your chances of actually succeeded in
school oniony look you've got a look at
the processes you haven't haven't gone
into the army you've said yourself you
probably would be done precisely so the
army saved you and what I'm saying is we
need more projects like that to help
these young people and throwing their
families out of homes does not bail
isn't something that's happened to them
it's
consequence of their behavior they've
been expelled you make a choice every
lots of people have bad circumstances
lots of people are in single parents you
make a choice do I get myself on the
straight and narrow or do I shove a
zombie knife down my pants
7 and start robbing people in the street
I don't know if you make a choice itself
yeah I think I think you are the product
of your environment at seven these kids
are very young under 28 the idea that
you then break up the family Oh will you
or you make them homeless when you're no
no wait hold on Nick the evidence that
Perret parenting is crucially important
in in this and gathering etcetera
etcetera yeah okay let's just make the
Hat render the family homeless and chuck
them out the bar oh right that's really
gonna help I want to see I was probably
one Housley always talking about